- Oh!
- [Group] Oh my god!
- Puppy!
- Babies!
- It's okay, it's okay.
- Me!
Come on!
- So cute!
Heart attack!
(playful music)
(speaking in foreign language)
- Sup guys, we're in
Buzzfeed with the puppies.
Shall we name the dogs?
- I think he- uh, he or she?
- Check.
- Okay.
She's Shy Girl
- He's Popo.
- [Group] Popo!
- [I.M] Why?
- Cutie.
- Tarzan and Jane.
- So cute!
- I'm gonna take him home!
Okay, okay, okay.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Rock.
- [Group] Rock.
- Me too.
- Jazz?
- Jazz, no!
Do you know Chet Baker?
- I fall in love too easily!
- Oh, you wanna pick it?
- [Group] Pick, pick, pick!
(speaking in foreign language)
- Powerful.
- Energetic.
- Good senior.
- A respectful senior.
- Sexy!
- Cool guys.
- Handsome.
- Savage.
- Jane picked one.
(speaking in foreign language)
- I think our members is more sexy.
- [Group] Oh.
- And more good english
better than last year.
(speaking in foreign language)
I wanna play with dogs.
He's not coming, nobody's coming to me.
(speaking in foreign language)
These puppies!
(laughter)
- Best idea!
(speaking in foreign language)
- Yeah?
- Your name?
(speaking in foreign language)
- Present was from the
past and the future comes
from the present, so I like myself right now.
- Yeah, I agree.
- You too?
- Yeah, me too.
(speaking in foreign language)
- So cute!
- I like my rap lyrics in Shine Forever
because they all follow my rap.
- My lyrics on Destroyer, like belief rap.
- Yeah, I like it.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Shownu.
- Me?
- [I.M] Why, why, why?
- He has a good body.
- Thank you.
- Hey, focus on me!
- I'm sorry!
- Concentrate!
- I want Wonho's body.
- Why?
- Hey, focus on me!
- I'm sorry!
- I want abs!
- You have!
- No, just one pec.
- Okay!
(speaking in foreign language)
- Follow me.
- No!
- Don't follow him.
- Follow my outfit, come on.
- Pass!
Next question!
- Hey, I wanna collaborate with you!
- This one, this one, this one!
- Okay, next question!
- Be quiet!
(speaking in foreign language)
- Harry Potter.
- Oh, Harry Potter.
- 100 percent.
- Twilight, vampire.
Pick it up, pick it up.
- [Group] Oh!
- Last question!
It is for Shownu.
(speaking in foreign language)
- I think I'm just leader.
- He's the leader!
(speaking in foreign language)
- He's so energetic.
- So cute!
- I want to adopt this guy.
- Let's go home together.
- You can adopt these cute puppies
at North Shore Animal League America.
- Bye!
- We're going to adopt them,
we're going to adopt you guys.
- [Group] Bye!
(singing)
(air rushing)
(creaking)